right joining us now is the author of
the new American Revolution RNC
spokesperson Kelly mcenany's with us Fox
News national security strategist dr.
Sebastian Gorka and Fox News contributor
Doug shawn kalei let's start with you I
think you know the press call me as oh
memo if there's some satellite he took
it to me an associate of his campaign
did something it would be good to find
that out okay that sounds like he wants
the investigation to be thorough
complete and even if it's people around
him he wants to know who did what and
after a year plus we have nothing right
Shawn that sounds like the opposite of
obstruction of justice that sounds like
a president fully cooperating with the
investigation and to echoed that Jim
Comey says in his book that none of his
conversations with the president rose to
the level of illegalities there is no
there there
to quote Peter struck there's no there
there with collusion there's no there
there with obstruction he's been cleared
by the Intel committee Robert molar I
said you're not a target of this
investigation rod Rosen Steines edit and
commis memo he says to the president
three times you are not under
investigation this president has
cooperated he should be absolved and
robert muller needs to pack up go home
move on you know wouldn't think of the
week we had dr. Gork aware first you
have the congressional criminal
referrals Hillary Clinton Loretta Lynch
struck Paige Comey
mccade anybody involved in the dossier
then you have the criminal referral by
the IG as it relates to Andrew McCabe
now today we have James Comey himself he
is under investigation
everything you're part of predicting as
I was that this is all going to backfire
on them because the very thing they were
accusing the president of they
themselves were guilty of what a week
it's been you read the parts of the
Declassified memos today James Comey
says that he said I don't do weasel
moves I don't make slimy tricks well
guess what he is one six foot seven
slimy weasel that's what he did if you
read this what do we now know Sean we
know that he told the president
you're not the target we know the
president told him I want a clean bill
of health for my whole campaign get to
the bottom of it James Comey refused to
make a public statement to the effect
that the president is not the target and
that he wants a clean bill of health but
what did he do he leaked the fallacious
Russian propaganda accusations that he
told Congress later were unverified and
salacious that's what he gave to the
press how is that not biased Sean let me
you know I'm watching the Democrats
today the whole Russia collusion
narrative is falling apart Doug the
whole thing so now they're gonna file a
frivolous lawsuit probably go judge
shopping and and I hope they get a
liberal judge that will you know after
the special counsel rod Rosen's team was
key this week he told the president that
he's not the target in either
investigation the one in New York or the
Robert Mullins Special Counsel
investigation that's another way of
saying they never found any evidence of
any type of collusion and for the
Democratic Party they can't let it go
that now this is gonna be their issue
going into 2018 sounds like a bad idea
to me well Sean it's not only you and
Republicans who think it's a bad idea
people like congresswoman Jackie Speier
from California said what I believe that
this is trying to overtly politicize an
investigation that has not been
completed you're right as of now we have
no evidence of collusion but for the
Democrats to try to turn it into a
political football in the midst of an
election campaign runs the risk of a
backfire and is overreaching we saw that
once before in 1998 in the midterm
elections when arguably the Republicans
overreached and I would urge my fellow
Democrats not to make the same mistake
you know Mallick at all the deep state
actors sebastien you and I talked at
length about this if you look at all of
them the idea that Hillary Clinton we
know she committed felonies and we know
there was an exoneration before an
investigation we also know that they
used the phony Clinton bought and paid
for dossier created by a foreign age
using Russia Russia government sources
and then you use that as a basis of FISA
warrant to spy on Americans it seems
these things now this is what America is
going to focus on Americans believe in
the right of privacy and they don't
believe in frivolous warrants based on
political opponents paying foreign
sources that use Russian sources to lie
to courts to get warrants to spy on
people that's the average American
that's the America that I know that's
driven by common sense but you just
played the audio where James Comey with
a straight face says yeah it would have
been better if Clinton had won because
of her upstanding attitude to justice
and law and order I mean is that a bad
joke from cattle futures to serve a gate
this is a woman who we know has
committed felonies what felonies has
Donald Trump committed in the last 71
years zero Sean this is how deep the
corruption is in a swamp and the fact
that these people go on book tours when
they should be in the dock tells you how
big a job the president has before him
you know Kaylee and watch this we keep
hearing about the big blue wave that
might happen here I think look if I
don't want the Democratic Party to
listen to Doug show that vices keep do
keep doing what they're doing and if the
Republicans can fix a couple of things I
would find ways to cut back on that
omnibus bill which they have an ability
to do I would secondly I'd get the money
and fully fund that wall and get it get
the building started and do it
expeditiously and the third thing I
would do for the Republicans is fix
health care and if they do those three
things I don't think they would lose
anything there's no doubt about it and
the president has worked very hard at
getting those things done we need
partners in Congress to fund the wall as
you noted the President does want to
rein in spending he has said that but
the Democrats Sean gave us a big
indication of what their playbook is for
2018 today when they filed this
frivolous publicity stunt of a lawsuit
and that is Russia Russia Russia they
will scream it from the rooftops there
is no basis in truth these are
conspiracy theories that they're
peddling
by the way the DNC's bankrupt they have
six million six million dollars in debt
so I don't know how they're funding this
multi-million dollar lawsuit but they
ought to be careful because Brad Parr
scale from the Trump campaign said I'm
going to expose this DNC corruption
through Discovery we're going to look at
why you partnered with fusion GPS we are
going to use this lawsuit to find out
why you didn't turn over your server
the DNC we're coming after you and your
narrative for 2018 is not working all
right Doug I'm gonna give you the last
word just get bad to keep giving them
bad advice well I think I give good
advice but I would say the Democrats run
on issues try to do a deal to make the
dreamers and the wall get done it's good
for both sides they're not going to do
what we need progress and if there's a
rigorous that will benefit the country
and the Democrats and indeed the
Republicans because showing what's so
bad about this is the real winner in all
of this is Vladimir Putin president G
and all the autocrats who see us ripping
ourselves apart hurting our position
globally when as you said quite
correctly the president is dealing with
very serious foreign policy problems
similar North Korea they wanted a so
discord in the country and they've
succeeded a hundred percent but the
president still successful which I'll
I'll point out in a few minutes sorry
thank you all